I stole em immediate I was at the front
desk of the hotel and the front desk
ladies screaming oh Jesus
Jen's out oh Jesus I said what's wrong
she's my back my back has just been
killing me for months so you should try
Viking it said no I'm trying Jesus I
said nice try Viking she said you should
try Jesus said now my back is great
you just write have Jesus have vicodin
to get that out so back maybe real
vicodin placebo Jesus for your pet I
don't go to church sometimes he would be
Holy Ghost and I can't get with that
people I think the Holy Ghost is just a
reason for people to dance like an ass I
love Jesus I'm sweating sweating so much
with a love like that I think still
think you a good person if you sit down
I think the only goes is fake cuz you
people want to get inserts when they had
danced around other people that's Holy
Ghost I'm surprised a rapper hasn't said
that it made it into a dance already
oh yeah I did it [ __ ] on camera no
rappers can still improve me oh there
goes there just really gross
I think the whole egos is fake nobody
ever gets the holy calls anywhere else
nobody ever catch the Holy Ghost in
Arby's like what Papa power
[Applause]
welcome to that solo fest security room
the venue is 300 but the security room
is 300 times two we've got 600 employees
dedicated to security making sure your
experience is one of the purest